schluss mit lustig auf mallorca hatten
hunderte menschen am wochenende
getrunken getanzt und gefeiert ohne
schutzmasken zu tragen und ohne den in
ganz spanien vorgeschriebenen
sicherheitsabstand von mindestens
eineinhalb metern einzuhalten
bilder wie diese sorgten bei der
spanischen regierung für empörung
fehlverhalten mit konsequenzen mallorca
hatte daraufhin eine besonders strenge
masken pflicht erlassen und alle
vergnügungslokal im herzstück des vor
allem von deutschen touristen gern
besuchten ballermann an der playa de
palma zwangs geschlossen
mallorca insider befürchten von
schärferen auflagen bis zur schließung
von einzelnen bars oder ganzen
straßenzügen alles ist möglich die
bußgelder für illegale partys in
illegalen räumlichkeiten wurden schon
auf bis zu 600.000 euro erhöht auch eine
schließung von lokalitäten über drei
jahren kann bei verstößen verfügt werden
ballermann star mickie krauses mir jetzt
zugeschaltet von der insel nämlich an
micky wie sieht's aus und partymeile
wieder zu wie schlimm trifft es die
ballermann gemeinschaft ja ich habe
natürlich auch dieses video gesehen vom
vergangenen freitag ist schon wirklich
erstaunlich welche auswirkungen ein
solches video hat ich habe es mir
mehrmals angesehen
ich habe es nicht als party exzess
gesehen es wurde natürlich gefeiert es
wurden sicherheitsabstände nicht
unbedingt eingehalten aber es handelt
sich definitiv nicht um ein party exzess
in der bierstraße was ärgerlich ist
natürlich aufgrund einer location die
sich vielleicht nicht an die an die
abstandsregelungen erhalten hat sofort
die bier und schinkenstraße dicht zu
machen
das ist reine schikane wir wissen
natürlich alle der st auf tourismus ist
der regierung in spanien oder in madrid
ein dorn im auge und so kann man
natürlich jetzt auch versuchen wirklich
diesen tourismus ausbluten zu lassen
na also vermutet da eine stärkere
strategie der regierung dahinter diesen
ballermann
mallorca zu verändern also kein
verständnis für diese entscheidung auf
deiner seite sehen dass seine kollegen
genauso das sehen meine kollegen genauso
weil es einfach wirklich übertrieben ist
eine entscheidung nur aufgrund eines
videos und von bildern zu treffen wir
uns schinkenstraße zu zu schließen
das ist einfach zu viel zu brutal dass
das ist eine frechheit weil es einfach
auch locations gibt die sich wirklich an
die bestimmung gehalten haben die
sicherheitsabstände eingehalten haben
und ein wirklich gutes
sicherheitskonzept haben in bier und
schinkenstraße und die einfach jetzt
darunter leiden zu lassen dass eine
location vielleicht nicht diese abstände
eingehalten hat und nicht die bestimmung
sich nicht an die bestimmungen gehalten
hat das ist einfach unfair und natürlich
für für die vielen gastronomen ja den
wird eine existenzgrundlage ende
genommen
ja mickie krause machen was denn dann
aber also wir wissen oder wir sagen
jetzt mal diese entscheidung war einfach
überzogen und hat andere hintergründe
auf der anderen seite wir müssen uns an
bestimmte regeln halten auch beim feiern
geht denn überhaupt diese in der theorie
erdachte theorie feiern auf halber
flamme feiern aber nicht so doll feiern
aber mit abstand ist das überhaupt
umsetzbar seien mit abstand ist schon
möglich aber es geht erstmal darum wie
ich die gastronomie wieder zu
unterstützen
menschen die möglichkeit zu geben
arbeiten zu gehen also den kellner eine
perspektive zu geben den angestellten in
hotels in kneipen in pubs in lokalen das
ist ja das erste wichtige aber ein
konzept habe ich natürlich auch nicht
ich habe für mich beschlossen bis zum
ende des jahres keine auftritte zu
machen auch wenn es anfragen gibt in
sachen autokino und uns also ich habe
kein konzept aber ich glaube eine eine
schrittweise öffnung kann funktionieren
und wenn die möglichkeit besteht statt
mit 1000 leuten mit 200 leuten zu feiern
dann sollte man diese möglichkeiten
suchen